-Billy, welcome back.
How are you?
-I am fantastic.
-You know, I'm hanging in there.
I want to start
by congratulating you.
You were nominated again
for "Pose,"
a category you won last year
And we were talking a little bit
before this started.
It's a little different.
You come from Broadway.
You only get nominated onc
for a role.
-Yeah, you only win once
for a role
that you create on Broadway.
So, it's a really
interesting journey.
I'm very grateful
to be nominated again.
to be on "Pose,"
a show that is transformative.
Um, you know,
a show that truly is where
art meets activism for me,
which is a big deal
for me and my work.
So, I'm thrilled.
Thank you.
-Obviously, it's going to be
a bit of a different ceremon
this year, as circumstances,
you know, dictate.
And I think one of the thing
I'll miss the most,
and I don't think I'm alone, i
Billy Porter on the red carpet
-[ Laughing ]
-I hope -- No, again,
I do appreciate the glasse
that you brought to this,
which makes me think that
even if we have a Zoom Emmys
you will probably bring some
sort of effort to your work.
-Some joie de vivre.
You know, I'm giving you kafta
realness right now in my house
-I love it.
-It's a summer look.
It's fabulous and freeing.
[ Laughs ]
-Now, one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin,
actually got your actual hat
with the remote-control veil
-I saw that.
-And it was a real hat,
and it was an ordeal
to get the hat.
The hat does not travel alone.
The hat travels with someone
-It does not travel alone.
Yes, it travels
with Sarah Sokol,
who is the designer of the hat
And the hat is heavy.
-And how did you -- what gav
you the inspiration for the hat?
-We had been at
another awards show
where Billie Eilish
was in front of me,
and she was wearing this vei
over her Gucci situation.
And I said,
"Oh, that's cute, that's fun
but I would never cover my face,
because I've spent too lon
getting people to see my face.
-Yeah.
[ Both laugh ]
-And my stylist at the time,
Sam Ratelle, said,
"Well, what if we
could open and close it?
Would you be interested?"
And that's how it came about
and that's why we did it.
[ Both laugh ]
-Your show, "Pose," sadly,
was one of the many shows
that had to halt productio
due to the coronavirus.
-Yeah.
-You were actually slated
to direct an episode this year
-Yes.
-Was that something
you were excited about?
-Yeah, I'm totally --
you know, I am, as I say,
very often trying to be
the head bitch in charge.
So this means
I am writing a lot.
I have been directing a lo
in the theater.
I've been writing
So I'm trying to move that ove
into my film and television,
you know,
starting my new company.
You know, and trying to be
the change that I want to se
and be able to greenlight
my own projects
and being able
to say yes to myself
and being able to support
the stories
and give voice to the voiceles
in ways that only happen
when you have
that kind of power.
So I'm very, very excited about,
you know, enlarging
my territory, as it were.
-Another way that
you're trying to help out
is your campaign, Be A Hero.
Can you speak a little to that
-Yeah.
Be an Arts Hero is essentially
a grassroots campaign
to get the U.S. Senate to pass
an emergency arts relief act
by the end of this week,
by August 1st.
You know, so many people
don't understand
that it's the second largest
economic driver in the nation.
$877 billion in value
added to the economy.
4.5 the GDP.
You know we're talking the -
we're talking the financiers
language now.
You know, it's like the --
the economy in New York.
Broadway sold more tickets
than all of the New York
and New Jersey
sports teams together.
That's $1.8 billion
in ticket sales.
And right now,
during COVID, you know,
94% of the arts workers
have lost income.
64% have been fully unemployed
due to COVID.
You know, and we are just
reaching out
and calling to the Senate to
really get this relief package
specifically for arts workers,
with health insurance.
You know,
it's about the economy.
It's about, you know,
40% of the NEA grants
serve low-income, people
of color, and LGBTQ people
and veterans
and disabled communities.
Like, there's so much fundin
that is necessary in this crisis
in particular.
-I do think, too, and mayb
you can speak to this,
because, obviously,
Broadway is very glamorous
and I think people
have this idea that everyone
who works on Broadway
is making a fortune because,
you know, they read how much
"Hamilton" tickets are.
But most people, even on suc
an iconic strip of land
as Broadway, are just barely
making ends meet.
And sometimes I think,
at times like this,
we talk about things like,
you know, firemen and teachers
and we forget that, you know
people in the arts
also have families,
and they also
are trying to put food
on the table.
-Yeah, and we're working-class
especially on Broadway.
You know, we live hand-to-mouth.
I did it for 30 years.
It is not --
we're not rich, you know.
We're two to five paycheck
away from poverty,
just like everybody else.
And, you know,
this moment has illuminated that
in really stark ways.
And so we're calling --
we're calling on the people,
we're calling on our senators.
You know, we have an open letter
to our senators
to explore how to make sur
this relief package
is put through and that ou
people are taken care of.
-And I know this is
completely volunteer-run,
your organization.
-Yes.
-Where can people go
if they want to sign up
and lend a helping hand here
-Yes.
You can sign up at --
you can visit beanartshero.com
That's the best way
to get to us.
Beanartshero.com,
and that will take you
to different levels and layers
of how you can help.
-Well, obviously,
I'm a little biased,
but I do believe the arts
does a great amount
to enrich all of our lives
and you in particular
have certainly enriched ours
And congrats again.
-You're very sweet.
-It is just always such
a pleasure to talk to you.
-Thank you.
It's wonderful to be back,
and I can't wait
to see you in person.
-Same to you.